hello there I'm John Oliver host of last
week tonight an HBO show that is nothing
like Game of Thrones and not only
because it makes sense why I have a
British accent I'm here to tell you I'm
here to tell you about HBO now the new
standalone streaming service from HBO
now if you're the type of person who
doesn't even own a TV first of all never
say that it's not cool everybody hates
you but second of all you're in luck all
you need to sign up for HBO now is the
internet so you can get current HBO
shows like veep and classic HBO shows
like The Wire streams - you wear it
wherever there's an internet connection
and that's just what we're worth the
price alone just to stop your friends
from saying you've never seen the wire
oh my god you have got to see the wire
although to be honest you really do have
to see the wire it's amazing HBO now
offers everything you love about HBO
like sports and comedy specials and full
frontal nudity
the hatchery the trifecta of HBO it's a
lot like HBO GO
except you don't have to rely on your
parents password so so if if you have if
you have the Internet you can now enjoy
tons of HBO programming whenever you
want and if you don't have the internet
Wow
you should definitely get the Internet
there is some amazing stuff on there
some of the cutest and the most racist
things you will ever see are on the
internet so so maybe first check out
some videos of otters holding hands and
then work your way up to the Sopranos
what you haven't seen The Sopranos
you've got to see The Sopranos HBO now
available now on whatever this is
you